or you did win two in a row against
Prague to make that comeback in each
other think now yeah I mean chances
maybe will be slim but he just has to
keep the tension he has to keep
believing and he has to hope that Magnus
Carlton falls into the same trap that
Prague did a couple of days ago of
playing passively and uh this is a very
trendy variation in something very
similar we saw a huge Clash last season
when Magnus sacrificed his queen against
Gary and won a beautiful game so um yeah
here we see Gary stepping forward with
the pawn he's already castled and
rearranged his pieces on the first rank
white now he's getting ready to step
forward in the center
uh this is still quite well known stuff
I believe yep and we will see white gain
space in the center but black now will
strike back there we go we see a Trader
pawns and knocking down the middle of
the board if white steps forward now we
could see something reminiscent of the
first game of the day with Anish Gary
playing almost a French defense type
structure Anish while he goes for the
most natural looking move and now Magnus
Castle is the king
and again Anish has many options he can
develop the Knight as he's done another
option was just to actually pick up the
pawn in front of the king and move it
one square just to control the Circuit
of the Knight sitting on G6 black is a
bit cramped these two pawns are further
back than the two white Pawns in the
center therefore you're cramped and you
should be aiming to exchange pieces
that's the logic if you have less space
swap off pieces if you have more space
keep points keep pieces on the board
it's two squares are controlled and giri
does find that move
not only have you controlled the Black
Knight but you're getting ready to play
the most trendy idea in modern chess
you're getting ready to push Harry the
H1 forward another
one's actually just to develop the queen
now he does it and now he does it yeah
yeah I think he had to before it was too
late before he got steamrollered by the
white porn coming forward uh so he had
to put pressure on White Center that's
good chest wisdom again and uh okay
after a Trader pawns I was expecting the
black Bishop maybe to capture just to
put some pressure on white Central Pawn
but Magna says no he's going to take
with the rook and he might be lining up
for something that we call a thematic
exchange sacrifice in chess if white
gives uh enough time for example pushes
a pawn then sooner or later Magnus could
consider giving up his Rook for a night
I'm not sure whether you want to rush
that now but it is on the radar the
whole idea is yes you've given up a rook
for night but you win White's Central
Pawn and uh long term black has two
Pawns in the center which could start
marching down the board all to do with
that light Square Bishop that you
mentioned you know it's such a bad piece
and Anish he seems to be in a very
direct mood today and he's like okay I'm
gonna attack The Rook Rook takes a step
back and now we see a trade of Bishops
so Anish is just saying well I'm going
to just make those trades and make sure
those dark squares around the center are
timely weak for you Magnus so now if you
compare the remaining pieces on the
board white slight squared Bishop good
piece controls a lot of squares and
black slight Square Bishop a bad piece
um the nightmare scenario for black here
would be to let to be left in a good
night versus bad Bishop scenario stuck
defending its own pawns unable to get
active and okay Magnus dancing around
with his Knights meanwhile is he in a
little bit of trouble in this game
Magnus positionally strategically he's
yeah in a lot of trouble but he's active
enough for now to compensate for that so
magnus's activity is enough to kind of
be slightly worse and this pressure that
Magnus has against White's D4 Pawn is
enough just to tie anisha's Rooks down
and Magnus just making an improving move
giving a safe Square to the king
Gary while he's playing by the textbook
centralizing his work
the top players in the world incredible
it's not as if he's just racking up wins
against a bunch of bunnies he's
literally competing against the top
rapid players the top speed players in
the world and so far he's made it look
very simple I mean it could have been
more even Magnus has led a few uh
half-point slip here and there by a
couple of careless moves and uh Robert
Dalton says that shows us one there's a
pawn starting at the bottom of the board
ambition you love the pawns yeah we do
definitely like that piece yeah I think
he's been thinking the whole time wow
four minute thinking I really like this
night Retreat I've got to say Ivanka
from Anish giri
um do you think Magnus was feeling the
pressure
yeah he's certainly uh anticipating war
and ish is going to be doing next
because that night has a purpose you
know it's going to Spring over to the
afro-born and start prodding at some
weak pawns there on E6 and also there's
light squares and wow Magnus reacts with
that in a very direct way he says well
you cannot put your knight there and I'm
prepared to weaken my king and I think
this is quite a sensible Choice actually
because after all White's pieces are all
on the back row so they're not going to
attack the black king that easily so wow
I'm impressed yeah I'm very impressed
too I think Magnus had to choose this
because as you say if he'd taken a time
out maybe improve the White Queen then
sooner or later the Black Knight is just
going to Leap Forward and the White
Knight sorry yeah and uh
I mean there's ideas of attacking the
queen this Pawn is eternally weak this
Outpost in the center you could plant
one night here you could maybe later on
plant the other night there as well just
occupy this Square now it's more
difficult for Anish to kind of find the
ideal squares for his pieces this pump
push does also hint that you can
threaten to kick away this Knight active
measures it's not time to be waiting
around and
okay he does wait however he drops his
Knight back this makes a lot of sense
long term strategically you want to
reroute your knight but allow the
serious pressure against this Pawn in
the middle
now maybe the moment has passed as soon
as the black queen comes forward
and uh Magnus will put some pressure on
this pawn it does feel like only she's
playing it safe but he's in a must-win
situation remember and uh okay Magnus
doesn't play it safe okay okay Magnus is
the one taking risks suddenly instead of
bringing the queen to a very nice
defective uh defensive and active Square
uh sorry he pushes this Pawn forward
kicking the White Knight into the square
it wanted to use anyway
okay I mentioned that this is tempting
for black because you can win white
Central Pawn but suddenly Black's King
is very very open suddenly Black's pawns
start to fall as well and uh yeah I'm
worried here for magnus's King Knight
takes Pawn would be a threat
okay Anish it feels like he's been given
another second opportunity to get active
and uh right now this is the position I
don't think you have time to take this
Pawn simply this pawn and this Pawn uh
these two weaknesses in front of the
black king
they're up for grabs immediately you
have to be really careful there it's
you wear Magnus
to draw to secure the match why play in
such a risky fashion and there you go he
captures the Knight is just too
dangerous to allow the White Knight to
capture the pawn uh look away it's queen
of Rook they're just staring at a well
fortified pawn and he does what he takes
a pawn it makes no logical sense the
only thing I can justify this Pawn
capture with is maybe long term he wants
to use his Knight on the Square but
Black's covering that square with his
own Knight look at Black's pieces
suddenly they're pouring forward
this was not possible black Bishop is
now active but this was not possible if
White had taken with his Rook the black
Bishop is eternally tied down to the
defense of this weak Pawn
and he's scary he's broken all the
traditional rules we talk about there
you mentioned nimsovich Ivanka who wrote
a great book who kind of formed modern
positional chess understanding and he's
gone against all of that Knight takes
Knight Pawn takes yes he wants to get
his Knight in but after this bishop move
he pushed his ball forward what is this
Knight doing
suddenly if it ever moves if it moves to
either of these two squares the black
Bishop which is the worst piece on the
board would just trade itself off for
the White Knight happily and black is
left with a nice piece on F5 yeah now
Magnus is trading off Queens he's going
for towards the end game
it's just all gone wrong for Anish
he's just I don't like this is one of
the most bemusing confusing decisions
I've ever seen I must admit just in
terms of strategy the top players
they're also good at that part of the
game normally it just seems to be the
Magnus effect like Anish somehow doesn't
seem to
be just
playing in his in the way that we know
that he can play
and it's unsurprising I mean just take a
look at Black's pieces they've just
launched themselves forward The Rook is
on its perfect line I mean there's like
a sacrifice bring
on the F2 Square oh
lightning has struck twice and Magnus
finds the best move of course he does he
doesn't even Retreat his Knight he
doesn't keep it safe he gives up his
night for the pawn and the whole idea is
if the Knight is captured disaster Rook
takes Pawn
capitulation on the second rank
breakthrough and Checkmate is coming
yeah the white Bishop alone cannot hold
the fort if the white Bishop Retreats
The Black Queen just slides across and
she's going to join her two Rooks and
this poor King is just completely cut
off on the first round look at Black's
Rooks the power of them
it does bring up the analysis board just
while a niche Ponders whether to resign
or not but I was going to show just the
end game of the last battle between
YouTube so this was the final position
of game two if you remember uh he
resigned here because White's Rooks are
crashing in on this F7 square and uh now
let's flick through to the current
position and he's about to resign now
because Black's Rooks are coming in uh
sorry to crash through on the F2 Square
so it's it's basically the same pattern
yes this is more complicated with more
pieces on the board uh more complicated
middle game but it's the same pattern
it's just the same weakness uh just with
colors reversed
um so Magnus has pinpointed
um yeah just resigned now I mean the
problem is okay he takes the bishop
but we can fully expecting Magnus to
pick up his Rook on f8 and capture the
pawn on F2 and just ask her
what are you going to do about your
Bishop
Magnus uh leaning forward he looks like
he was getting ready to uh to celebrate
this Victory and he's down at 30 seconds
as well he throws his Knight in the way
but this won't save the day this night
can be captured by the black Brooks it
can even be captured by Black's Knight I
think
and that we see the Rook capture the
knights yeah this is the safe approach I
was expecting Magnus to go for something
a bit more flashy uh at least now one of
the Rooks can be removed from the board
so there won't be that immediately that
immediate breakthrough against the white
king okay anisha's kind of tricked
Magnus uh in a small way that was very
clever by a niche to survive but the
problem is you're not surviving for long
now rather than the second rank
breakthrough it's going to be the first
rank uh Black's Rook challenging White's
Rook you cannot take now you cannot
trade off those Rooks because Black's
Queen would swoop down recapture and
that would end in Checkmate on rank one
so uh okay everything disappears and at
the very end Black's gonna be a few
pawns up yeah he's so clinical he's not
giving a niche a single chance and
bearing in mind that Anish is in a
must-win situation he's just put that
nail in the coffin
yeah we will see everything get
exchanged the Queens are about to
disappear Magnus will emerge three pawns
ahead and Anish throws in the towel and
resigns and Shake three wins for Magnus
and it's over he wins the match horrible
day for Anish giri in San Francisco but
Magnus Carlsen is on fire